-will.i.am,
you are up right now, bud.
Pull the mic and see
what challenge you get.
Good luck.
-Boom.
-Yeah.
-I know you're gonna crush it.
I know you're gonna get it.
I know you're gonna crush it.
"Mega Mix Showdown"!
-♪ Mega Mix ♪
♪ What you sayin' over that ♪
♪ Mega Mix ♪
♪ What you sayin' over that... ♪
-Showdown.
-Alright, now, this is
a brand-new game,
and it is a showdown,
which means we're going
to need two mics, okay?
will.i.am, you and Saweetie
are going to face off
in this challenge.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Get ready. Get ready.
Okay, Saweetie,
come on over here.
Here's how "Mega Mix" works.
I'm going to spin the wheel,
and you'll get a category.
Then you'll have to go
back and forth,
singing different songs
in that category.
Let's see what category we hit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God.
Throwback Rap?!
With Saweetie and will.i.am?!
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Oh, sign me up.
I want to see this. Alright.
That means you'll be singing
some classic hip-hop songs,
but you're going to have to
make them work over the beat.
So follow along as the lyrics
pop up in front of you,
and we'll see how well
you can keep up.
Get your spots over there.
-Alright.
Ready?
-[ Clears throat ]
-will.i.am,
you're gonna start off.
-[ Laughs ]
-One, two, one, two.
-Uh...
-Yeah!
-Yeah.
-What's it gonna be, bud?
-Let's get it.
-Whew.
-Okay.
♪♪
-Hey.
Okay.
Yo.
♪ Just wakin' up
in the mornin' ♪
♪ Gotta thank God ♪
♪ I don't know,
but today seems kinda odd ♪
♪ No barkin' from the dog,
no smog ♪
♪ Momma cooked a breakfast
with a brand-new hog ♪
-♪ I'm sorry, Ms. Jackson ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I am for real ♪
♪ Never meant
to make your daughter cry ♪
♪ I apologize a trillion times ♪
-♪ Y'all gon' make me
lose my mind ♪
-What?
-♪ Up in here, up in here ♪
♪ Y'all gon' make me
go all out ♪
♪ Up in here, up in here ♪
-♪ Biggie, Biggie, Biggie,
can't you see? ♪
♪ Sometimes your words
just hypnotize me ♪
♪ And I just love
your flashy ways ♪
♪ Guess that's why they broke
and you're so paid ♪
-♪ Yo, I wish I was
a little bit taller ♪
♪ I wish I was a baller ♪
♪ I wish I had a girl
that looked good ♪
♪ I would call her ♪
♪ I wish I had a rabbit
in a hat with a bat ♪
♪ And a six-four Impala-pala ♪
-♪ No, I don't want no scrubs ♪
♪ A scrub is a guy that can't
get no love from me ♪
♪ Hangin' out the passenger side
of his best friend's ride ♪
♪ Trying to holla at me ♪
-♪ Return of the Mack ♪
♪ Ooh, Lord ♪
♪ Return of the Mack ♪
♪ Oh, God ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ Return of the Mack, I am ♪
-♪ Now let me welcome everybody
to the wild, wild West ♪
♪ A state that's untouchable
like Elliot Ness ♪
♪ The track hits ya eardrum ♪
[ Rapping gibberish ]
♪ In the city of sex ♪
-♪ Yo, when the pimp's
in the crib, ma ♪
♪ Drop it like it's hot ♪
♪ When the pigs
try to get at you ♪
♪ Park it like it's hot ♪
-♪ If I had to give you more ♪
♪ It's only been a year ♪
-Come on, hey.
-♪ Now I've got my foot
through the door ♪
♪ And I ain't going nowhere ♪
-Hey!
-♪ It took a while
to get me here ♪
♪ So I'm gonna take my time ♪
♪ Don't let that good ish
in my ear ♪
♪ So let me blow ya mind, hey ♪
-Hey!
-Oh, my God!
-That's how we do it!
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a standing ovation
right there. That's it.